[موسيقى]
حياه القهر هذ حياه الذل هذا هذا ذل هذ عش
بني ادمين هذا رجعونا بدل 50 100 سنه لورا
يعني ايام بدائيه البدائيه يمكن كانوا
احسن من حالتنا هيا مش حرب هذ مش حرب
لحماس وبس هذا بدهم يصفوا كل العالم وكل
الشباب وكل الاولاد حتى الاطفال هدول ايش
ذنبهم ايش عملوا لهم بس نفسي افهم ايش عمل
لهم هدول الاولاد اللي عمال مش لاحقين
عليهم ادويه
وعلاجات وعد لا غاز ولا اكل ولا شرب ولا
ايش ب فيش مقاومات حياه بالمره يعني هين
اللي عارفه ها بمسك الاكل بصير دايه رمل
تع سليله وينك يما مش عارفه ايش
اسوي يعني الله بقول العالم كله شايفين مش
عاملين ششي معان والله حرام
عليهم قديش كيلو العدسه يا حج 16 وغير هيك
اللي بدك اياه يا باشا ع ماسك
الكيس
م ما في عننا لا فراش ولا غطا وشبه معدوم
المكان ما فيش في ادنى مقومات الحياه اللي
بتليق في البشر في الع في القرن ال 21
ورغما عن ذلك استوعبنا الامر وتعايشنا ب
الظروف الموجوده من الساعه فجر اليوم
بالكاد بالكاد ندبر وجبه واحده في اليوم
للجميع للصغير وللمريض وللجميع لانه هذه
الحياه ما بتوز حياه
البشر من اول ما نصحى لحد ما ننام واحنا
بنطرد عشان لقمه ناكلها ولا عشان ميه
نعبيها بنقطع مسافات عشان نعبي ميه مالحه
او ميه حلوه سواء للاستحمام للجلي للشرب
احنا من اول الحرب لحتى الان هذا مش بس
احنا كل الناس عايشين على المعلبات الواحد
زهق من المعلبات واقول لك حاجه كمان سوء
تغذيه هذا سوء التغذيه اللي احنا بنعاني
منه طلع علينا على جلدنا طلع صار يطلع
دمامل واشياء زي هيك امراض جلديه
كلها مشتق ارجع لبيتي ولبيتي ول تختي
وداري وارجع اودي نشوف لنا حياه يعني غير
هالحياه ايش بدنا اكثر من هيك اقل ما فيها
نكون زي اول بس ايش بدنا فيها وكمان كنا
مقهورين من اول ما كناش يعني عايشين
هالعيشه والعالم مطالب ومجبر وملزم انه
يوفر ان بدل المعيشه اللي احنا كنا
عايشينها كل الاكلات مشتاقين لها مشتاقين
لل سنيتش للمقلوبه للحم لكل شي مشتاقين
يعني في المطر بتنقط علينا الخيمه شو نعمل
احنا هنا في عراء في صحراء وهذا حال الناس
كلها يعني انا مثلا انا بيت الضرر بيتي
راح هلقيت عفشي كله راح بدي انا انا مش بس
انا اللي بدي تعويض كل الشعب بده تعويض
احنا نفسيتنا تعبانه وكلنا واحنا نطلع من
مكان لمكان بنجري من موت لموت بنجري من
الموت بنطلع من موت بنروح على
موت